je dois être vu pour être cru telle
était la devise d'Elizabeth II et c'est
parce qu'elle voulait être vu que la
reine a multiplié tout au long de son
règne les voyages à travers le monde il
était important pour la famille royale
d'être aimé de son peuple important de
montrer à quel point elle était dévouée
à son service c'est même en ces termes
exactement que la future reine Élisabeth
II fait cette promesse le jour de sa
majorité
[Musique]
pour elle de faire une diplomatie neutre
politiquement mais efficace d'ailleurs
rien n'était laissé au hasard il y avait
les célèbres tenus vestimentaires qui
auraient pu paraître futile mais dont la
couleur ou l'accessoire était
minutieusement choisi comme un clin
d'oeil amical au pays qu'il accueillait
et puis et puis il y avait le caractère
humain de ses tournées la reine avait
conscience qu'en allant à la rencontre
des gens elle pouvait leur redonner le
sourire leur redonner de l'espoir elle
pouvait à son échelle contribuer à
remonter le moral des peuples et c'était
aussi ça l'objectif de ces voyages la
tournée royale des Windsor de Mike
kinelli à découvrir ce samedi à 21h sur
Public Sénat